et bien bonjour vous allez regretter
d'avoir cliqué là dessus la veille un
truc que je vous ai jamais dit c'est que
je déteste
certains bruits alors comme tout le
monde ya plein de bruits qu'on était ce
genre la craie sur le tableau et c'est
ces brûlages les aime pas comme vous
mais il ya des bruits que je laisse
particulièrement essayer les bruits
sourds est très fort le truc qui atterit
d'un coup comme ça hyper fort ça me sais
pas j'ai envie de partir en courant il
pleurait mais vraiment bizarre c'est pas
juste ça me fait mal aux oreilles ces
jeux psychologiquement je ressors
quelque chose de bizarre chez pas
grossier
peut-être que quand ma mère était
enceinte mon père me parlait avec un
mégaphone dans le côlon vente de ma mère
et ça m'a traumatisé je sais faire
explique assure la joueuse a vanté sur
twitter d'envoyer des vidéos de son
insupportable pourquoi parce
qu'aujourd'hui nouveau challenge
le essayer de ne pas quitter la vidéo
challenge vous m'avez donc envoyé des
sont absolument ignoble je sais pas
pourquoi nous inflige ça pour être
honnête je n'en ai aucune idée mais je
sens que c'est important à battants
tient squeeze j'espère que tu
apprécieras ce magnifique moment top des
bruits énervant beau parfait c'est
puisqu'il nous faut c'est parti donc je
vais regretter mon gaver à vernon ça va
ça va non franchement ça va en vrai ça
ça va moi perso je alors la craie c'est
sa façon mais remet longue c'est encore
pire puisque à la justin entendant
l'ongle frotter tu as la sensation qui
va avec c'est surtout un ongle et ça
c'est horrible
ok 2 m ok je vous avoue un truc ça je
fais tout le temps mais je suis le pire
ça je le fais tout en baies à tanger une
bonne excuse j'ai un toc en fait quand
je commande une boisson que j'ai payé je
vais la voir comme ça et en partance y
reste une goutte je vais pas être bien
je veux dire [ __ ] il reste 2 centimes
dans mon verre c'est quoi ça il faut que
je finisse ou deux centimes et ce serait
une grande preuve d'intelligence que de
retirer la paille pour finir le vert
voilà que je n'ai pas bon ah ça c'est
dur ça c'est très dur c'est pas et c'est
pas de pire ah si quand même
oh ça j'ai envie de ah non mais ce bruit
les accords il est énervant pourquoi
parce que généralement quand tu
l'entends c'est le matin au petit déj
cola ton frère ou sa soeur qu'elle a et
qui fait pas attention et qui fait son
grand fils de [ __ ] pardon excusez moi je
me sens lancé le matin quand vraiment
quand tu mets ton pied en dehors du lit
moi perso pendant une heure minimum faut
que personne ne parle hyper dans mon
coin faut ici on parle ça me fait chier
ils tétouan joséphine et c'est
généralement à ce moment là que
j'entends les gens mangeaient saison le
midi je m'en bats les couilles j'ai dû
me dire [ __ ] est très sale mais le
matin c'est [ __ ] je vais te couper la
tête
bref à huy les trucs deyris emerse
affreux chaîne entendu une fois temps
est ce que c'est vraiment ça [ __ ] on
pige à manger ça me file la gerbe
alors j'ai un délire avec l'essai mère
je ne comprends pas je sais pas ce que
c'est chez parce que c'est censé être
l'axé est ce que va faire le vieux mec à
faire un tube au chu un vieux coup on se
chuchoter plus de montaure arrêter de
dire ça les adultes ça m'énerve relaxing
eating soon sa relaxe des gens vraiment
[ __ ] c'est ouf
non mais vraiment quoi y est vraiment
7200 personnes qui adorent qui ont dit
[ __ ] entendre des [ __ ] de bruits de
bouche hyper dégueulasse moi j'adore ça
me plaît que c'est génial
ah c'est vrai je suis charmé mode parce
que ça peut faire du bien des gens c'est
pas bien de se moquer de ce qu'il peut
faire du bien des gens sachant qu'en bus
non ça ne fait pas de mal pas là ça me
fait du mal je suis j'ai cliqué dessus
mais t'es pas obligé de cliquer dessus
mais elle le fait avec plusieurs types
de nourriture et du coup ça sonne pas
pareil c'est ça je découvrais cm en
plaine vidéo c'est génial non plus elle
mange ça comme une sauvage mec
oh on aurait dit que c'est ton imac
c'est là son truc
attention j'aime prendre la communauté
asc maires de france sur le dos l'a fait
ok tout tu sais pas le mal que ça me
fait plus tard non sans déconner je sais
pas je comprends pas d'élire données smr
si ça vous fait du bien tant mieux ça
vous fait du mal n'occupait plus jamais
là dessus moi c'est mon cas plus jamais
c'est fini merci arnaud demare fait
découvrir ça c'est vraiment ignoble
alors 4 bill qui nous envoie une vidéo
jeudi avec ligier richier guy ritchie
hachey aujourd'hui voici c'est un thème
ne s'était pas supportable arrêté c'est
pas supporter à faisait drôle c'est
juste drôle de m l'intro de quelqu'un
d'affilée comme ça mais ça marche avec
tout le monde tu mets n'importe quelle
place de me gérard schiste est pareil
shiloh rodez et mer français tient à
tanger par la smr français chez wayne
j'en ai promis dit enfin attendez je
reviens je vais voir sur la dune août en
plein de vidéos à en apprécier ce qui se
passe il reste 6 me dutin on est bien à
smr binaural 2000 red deer cleaning
watts tâches qu'on voit là al assad ya
ça c'est typique à son horrible qui
silva fait en fait à sa simule comme
s'il entrait dans tourner oreilles à toi
il va y aller à quoi je rigole silva à
la perceuse ça me fait hurler de rire
[Musique]
mais là franchement honnêtement je peux
comprendre tu vois tu as l'impression
que le truc et la voilà il ya un concept
alors claude c'est juste times aucun
kelka manche collé à son oreille c'est
hyper agréable une très belle vidéo
j'ai adoré la qualité du son je vais
d'écouter plusieurs fois merci beaucoup
cette tête regarde mon âme
alors au sein tout satisfaisant ab je
connais je connais le piège aux 92 %
vont devenir fou en regardant cette
vidéo là m'a fâché au bo si j'en dis du
mal je me faire craquer par le network a
encore une vidéo de quelqu un qui mâche
j'avoue ça fait vraiment partie des
pires bruit pour moi c'est vraiment
l'une des pires choses aux cadeaux à
main c'est pas ici qu'on doit te cacher
puisque a pris la grosse tête père de la
logopédie rejette pas la haye mais mon
couplet dans la chanson bravo bruit du
décollage ou l'atterrissage d'un avion
mes mecs c'est pas du tout le bruit de
décollage et d'atterrissage d'un avion
c'est juste une fréquence hyper aiguë au
lycée y avait ce délire là de fréquences
ou tu faisais écouter et il y en a qui
pouvait l'entendre d'autres qui pouvait
pas l'entendre parce qu'il entendait
moins bien et moi j'entendais pas jeter
la mia quoi les gars y'a quoi
ouais quand même pas se moquer je le
voyais comme ça mais c'est le corps d'un
enfant de 5 ans et demi et c'est l'idée
d'un enfant de 5 ans et demi aussi
qu'est ce qui se passe là vous voyez par
le commissionner pas vos enfants s'ils
font vous rendez compte
ce jour-là au commissariat de lens
réunion de crise dans les bureaux de la
crim
malgré son jeune âge le suspect se
serait montré très violent
un ongle sur un kimono afp la cbr
spécifique génial squeeze le pire sont
s'est gratté un kimono mec stop c'est
quoi ça
ah c'est la suite du mec avec son
chargeur je crois à voilà ça c'est
exactement ce genre de son que je
supporte pas c'est les trucs vraiment
grave et fort comme ça chez pas pourquoi
j'y arrive pas c'est exactement ce sont
là je supporte pas c'est le truc grave
et fort et sur l'aa j'ai envie de mettre
dans un coin est plus riche vous cher
c'est affolant grégoire reprocher j'ai
vu ça fait partie des pires sont
possibles les amis bien à pas mal c'est
vrai qu'il est dégueulasse celui là
[ __ ] le marqueur qui est tout sauf à
ça par contre je comprends regarder ça
c'est un bruit d'aspirateur ça peut
aussi être d'ailleurs un bruit d'avion
-un finalement ça je comprends pas ce
que ça à bruit sourd et continue et très
régulier et du coup ça peut
effectivement te relax et ça occupe en
quelque sorte son esprit et du coup tu
t'endors moi je sais que ça par exemple
sur moi ça marche dans l'avion par
exemple je peux m'endormir facilement
sauf qu un siège de devant est collé à
toi parce qu'à force de mettre un
maximum de gens dans le même avion alors
tiens c'est youtube est insupportable
mais on aime quand même vous sentez la
blague arrivé depuis aujourd'hui on se
trouve sur wall e cri du diable de
tasmanie juste horrible
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
one voice est tellement improbable tu
sais on lire les vidéos avec ce film un
animal et il fait c'est les bruits de
bouche à sa place au la saloperie le
bruit le plus sévèrement du monde a pas
mal à
c'est très stressant à abbès a alors si
je peux me permettre je peux me
permettre de juger ce montage audio ou
pas bon alors carrément le moustique qui
passe et il revient il reste pas dans
ton oreille la 1ere qui l'enfermé dans
ton oreille mec non paiement il fait
juste j'espère que ça va marcher mais je
me suis pris le micro nombre
[Musique]
on dirait un homme de 82 ans et qui fait
l'amour c'est génial oh ils sont
mignonnes cet antigène trop les
dentistes tellement inoffensif
regardaient las ce qu'elle a l'air de
prendre du plaisir et banon et lui non
plus alors arrêtez tous n'a plus de sens
mais bon je suis hyper content d'avoir
fait cette ville j'ai passé un très bon
moment merci d'avoir fait découvrir la
smr parce que j'en ai entendu parler
mais je ne m'étais jamais trop penché
sur le sujet et grâce à vous je ressors
moins bête de cette vidéo ne prenez pas
mal les femmes des mères mais c'est
quand même j'ai envie de faire la morale
de 20 modes mais si vous aimez les
semaines à votre problème mais je trouve
ça quand même mon chouchou
merci pour tous et sont dégueulasses
vraiment big merci c'est fantastique
j'ai envie d'un boucher soit jusqu'à fin
de la journée maintenant c'est
d'ailleurs ainsi le challenge bravo à
vous c'était très amusant et à bientôt
[Musique]